from killer dolls to mind-bending sci-fi
these sequels had us asking did that
really just happen but the real twist a
12 year old defeating a serial killer in
one of these Wild follow-ups
20 years before a Spider-Man trilogy hit
theaters writer directors some Remy
launched his career with the cult horror
flick the Evil Dead in 1981. starring
Bruce Campbell as a lovable dead-eyed
Slayer Ash Williams it tells the story
of a group of friends at a remote cabin
who accidentally Unleashed demonic
forces when these demons begin to
possess his companions Ash is forced to
take Extreme Measures to stay alive and
ultimately escape from the Carnage when
Evil Dead 2 was released six years later
a wrecked on the story of the original
film acting more as a remake than a
direct sequel the second film starts
with a recap of the first movie which
drastically changes the plots and the
events that occurred in the Evil Dead
obviously many viewers were left
confused about what was going on and why
the sequel ignores what happened in the
first entry of the series The Changes
were largely a result of the fact that
Remy didn't have the rights to reuse his
own footage from the first film
therefore he had to shoot certain scenes
over again or making some modifications
along the way this explains why Ash's
seen returning to the cabin with a new
girlfriend in tow and without much
mention of the friends of his who were
presents the first time around you
bastard
why are you torturing me like this why
when Sylvester Stallone's Rocky was
released in 1976 the scene was said for
what would become one of the most
successful sports movie franchises in
history this series focuses on the
career of little-known boxer Rocky
Balboa as he grows into a worldwide
sensation following a dramatic fight
with heavyweight champion Apollo Creed
Rocky goes through some pretty tough
times throughout the film series by
Rocky 5 the Italian Stallion is forced
into retirement due to the physical toll
of his fight with Ivan Drago in fact
he's suffering from some serious brain
injuries and takes up the job of a
trainer mentoring a new Young boxer who
is rising through the ranks the 1990
film ends with Rocky getting into a
street fight and leaving the sport for
good when Rocky returns and Rocky Balboa
in 2006 the Now 60 year old former boxer
comes back to the ring to fight an
actual heavyweight champion who is in
the prime of his career a sixth
installment essentially foregoes all of
the Lessons Learned in the previous
films where the near senior citizen
continuing to fight despite his his
previous Health scares and frailties no
Rocky you suffered severe brain trauma
well he could be wrong
she don't slash a series a Halloween
franchise first began in 1978 when John
Carpenter introduced the world to the
mass killer Michael Myers starring Jamie
Lee Curtis as final girl Lori Strode the
first film is a stone cold classic but
as you might expect from a franchise
that consists of 13 films and numerous
other media properties it was always
going to turn into something of a
convoluted mess regardless it's still
strange that Halloween H2O flat out
dismisses everything that came after the
1981 film Halloween 2 ignoring an entire
three film story arc that's centered on
the character Jamie Lloyd Jamie is
Lori's daughter who grows up with the
Foster family following the death of her
mother she becomes a target of a certain
Mass killer and is eventually murdered
during the events of Halloween the curse
of Michael Myers in Halloween H2O it is
revealed that Laurie never died at all
having faked her death to try and escape
from Myers not only does this movie
retcon her death but it makes no mention
of Laurie having a daughter naughty
events that take place during Jaime
Halloween movies
although the Resident Evil movie
franchise is based on the video game
series The narratives and characters
from the live-action films have
generally been separate from the iconic
Capcom IP largely the work of writer and
director Paul W S Anderson the sub
franchise began in 2002 with the release
of Resident Evil starring Mila Jovovich
as protagonist Alice as she battles the
malevolent Umbrella Corporation and an
outbreak of zombies the first sequel
arrived in 2004 with Resident Evil
apocalypse following Alice as she
escapes from umbrella and attempts to
flee from the growing infestation in
Raccoon City three years later Resident
Evil Extinction continued the franchise
with Alice now journeying through the
Mojave Desert as the zombie infection
has spread across the entire planet one
of the main gripes fans have had with
this third film is a way that it has
little connection with its predecessors
and starts afresh while ignoring major
events from both Resident Evil and
Resident Evil apocalypse examples of
this include Alice's unexplained
telekinesis Powers a well worldwide
apocalypse that happens completely off
screen and a whole host of characters
that have seemingly disappeared between
the second and third entries
I'm missing you already
[Applause]
Steven Spielberg burst onto the
Hollywood scene in 1975 when he directed
The highly acclaimed Thriller Jaws a
huge financial success it spawned an
entire franchise with multiple movies
that involve various other sharks
terrorizing the Brody family the first
Jaws 2 arrived in 1978 while the most
recent was Jaws the Revenge in 1987. the
immediate predecessor to this final film
was the 1983 movie Jaws 3D as the name
suggests it utilize 3D technology that
required audiences to wear special
glasses to get the full effect the story
largely follows a brody family as Mike
Brody attempts to stop a rogue great
white shark at SeaWorld Mike portrayed
by Dennis Quaid works at the theme park
and is in a relationship with a woman
called K Morgan the fourth film doesn't
just ignore the ending of his
predecessor it doesn't acknowledge Jaws
3D in any way in the later movie Mike is
a marine biologist rather than a Sea
World employee he has played This Time
Around by Lance guest and has a wife
called Carla and they both take on a
shark that seems of a personal Vendetta
against the family for some though the
fact that Jaws Revenge essentially
pretended that jaws 3D had never existed
is for the best after all the film was
panned by critics and fans
after the success of the Matrix a film
that grossed almost half a billion
dollars against a budget of just 63
million dollars the wachowski's got to
work on a pair of back-to-back sequels
to conclude the story The Matrix
Reloaded sees Neo in full possession of
his powers as the one as he continues to
work with Morpheus and Trinity to free
Humanity from the computer simulation
reloaded actually ends with more than
one Cliffhanger the first deals with the
fact that agent Smith has seemingly
downloaded into the real world by taking
over the mind of a human called Bane
with the film's Final Shots padding over
his unconscious body next to Neo the
cause of Neo's pastel state has shown a
few minutes earlier when he helps the
crew of the Nebuchadnezzar escape from a
group of pursuing Sentinels he somehow
destroys them with the power of his mind
but the sheer effort causes him to fall
into a coma by the time the Matrix
Revolutions happens though this fact is
pretty much discarded there is never any
real explanation given as to why Neo is
able to destroy machines outside of The
Matrix the third film just moves forward
without addressing the strange events
inviting fan theories at the real world
of the cyberpunk franchise might just be
another level of the simulation
why Mr Anderson why why do you persist
what began Life as a Michael Crichton
novel turned into a Sci-Fi media
franchise that has grossed almost 2
billion dollars in total starting with
1993's Jurassic Park everyone's favorite
prehistory inspired film series expanded
with two sequels in 1997 and 2001. the
Lost World Jurassic Park and Jurassic
Park 3. even though he never made an
appearance in a second installment the
third follows Dr Alan Grant as he
travels to Isla sauna to help rescue a
young boy trapped among the dinosaurs
that inhabit the area the ending of
Jurassic Park 3 sees a surviving group
made up of Dr Grant and Kirby family
escape from Isla sauna when they are
rescued by the U.S military as they fly
away in a helicopter to safety they see
several pteranodons also soaring through
the sky having been let out of the Avery
that housed them earlier in the film in
many ways the new Jurassic World Series
is a soft reboot of the franchise rather
than a proper continuation of the story
despite the numerous links to the
original energy that's why it's
understandable that Jurassic world
wouldn't address all of the issues
thrown up in Jurassic Park 3 and as
predecessors but the fact that it makes
no mention of the tyranitans and their
apparent escape from Isla sauna is still
pretty baffling well they captured that
they spread out across the globe these
are answers that the audience will never
know as Jurassic world simply
disregarded the ending of Jurassic Park
3 entirely
when Highlander had Cinema screens in
1986 and introduced viewers to a group
of immortal Warriors that can only be
killed by beheading Christopher
Lambert's character Conor MacLeod is
mentored by another Immortal played by
Sean Connery who reveals how the
Immortals are locked in a centuries-long
battle as they attempt to absorb each
other's Powers the tagline of the film
was famously there can be only one but
that didn't seem to apply to the movie
itself Highlander was followed by two
films as well as novels comics and the
television series Highlander 2 the
quickening isn't doubtedly the worst
movie in the Highlander franchise it
basically tosses out every good idea
from the first movie and goes on a
bizarre New Direction revealing that the
Immortals are actually exiled aliens
from an ancient Planet a rare example of
a film with a zero percent rating on
Rotten Tomatoes the sequel proved to be
a box office failure and has largely
been left forgotten in the series taking
all that into account it is easy to see
why director Andrew morahan and the
writers behind Highlander 3 chose to
ignore everything about the quickening
instead suggesting that the third film
is a true sequel to the original
Highlander many fans don't consider
Highlander 2 Canon and the fact that the
film is so lousy is definitely part of
the reason why
you have the manage of a goat and you
smell like a donkey
and you have no knowledge whatsoever of
your potential
the boy is a 2016 release that follows
Nani Greta Evans as she moves to the UK
to watch a couple's child when she
arrives Greta is shocked to learn that
she is actually tasked with looking
after a porcelain doll named Brahms this
figure is based on a young boy he was
killed in a fire 20 years ago his
parents have struggled to move on and
are obsessed with the doll as the story
progresses it seems that the doll may
actually have a life of his own near the
end of the film though it's revealed
that the human Brahms actually survived
the fire and has been living in the
walls as he moves the doll around after
the Disturbed man attempts to kill Greta
and her friend Malcolm she manages to
fatally stab him with a screwdriver
allowing them to escape Brahms The Boy 2
acts as a direct sequel to the first
film released in 2020 and taking place a
number of years after the boy it sees a
young family move into the home with a
terrible event of the first film took
place the porcelain doll has somehow
been repaired and now he's definitely
100 possessed by a supernatural Force
consider ring that the big twist at the
end of the boy was that it's grounded in
reality the change makes the sequel a
much different much less entertaining
movie
based on the 1991 novel of the same name
by Brett Easton Ellis American Psycho is
a 2000 horror film that stars Christian
Bale a serial killer Patrick Bateman
with the aid of his good looks charm and
socially conscious Yuppie Persona
Bateman kills a variety of big dims and
gruesome ways while continuing to evade
Justice the film concludes in a way that
makes it unclear which of the events
actually took place if any and whether
Bateman is aware of the reality of his
situation American Psycho 2 is a
standalone sequel that sees Mila Kunis
take on the role of a serial killer who
murders her classmates at University in
an effort to secure a coveted position
there's little meaningful connection
between the sequel and American Psycho
which is because the film was not
intended to be a sequel originally
instead it was adapted from a screenplay
entitled the girl who wouldn't die that
was not part of the same fictional
Universe in American Psycho 2 Patrick
Bateman appears extremely briefly and
without clearly showing his face
obviously no longer played by Christian
Bale after the Bateman is killed by a 12
year old it becomes clear that this is
far from a proper sequel to Mary
Herron's masterpiece
foreign